الى نموذجا فريد للعائلات السعوديه
الرياضيه قدمته الام نرمين رضا وابنها عبد
الله رضا ضمن دوره الالعاب السعوديه 20 22
والتي تعد اكبر حدث رياضي وطني في تاريخ
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وذلك باعتلائها
منصه تتويج في ختام منافسات السباق
الثلاثي حيث توجت اللاعبه الام بفضيه
السيدات واللاعب الابل البرازيه الرجال
الحساب الرسمي للجنه الاولمبيه والبرلمبيه
السعوديه
وذلك بمناسبه نجاحهما في تسجيل اسماءهم في
تاريخ السجلات الرياضه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
نرمين كيف كان شغلكم بالتتويج مع بعض
كعائله في هذا الحدث التاريخي في المملكه
[ضحك]
بس هذه دروس تحت اهم دروس الرياضه اننا
نستسلم وان شاء الله يعود
ويعني يصل الى الهداف اللي هو كان راسهم
نفسه
والدتك ام عبد الله الكريمه هل كنت اتوقع
الفوز ومن كانت حظوظه اكبر قبل الدوري
سنين
الحمد لله الحمد لله طيب ام عبد الله
نرمين انت فزتي بفضيه سباق السيدات في
ختامنافسات السباق الثلاثي كيف كان شعورك
اولا بهذا الفوز الفردي
وعمل اكثر بس اكيد يعني
خصوصا في عمري فكان شعور جميل واكيد كنت
يعني اعمل من وراء همم تحقيقه ولكن الا ما
يكون في همم شكل
طيب عبد الله كان في صوره كثير جميله
ومعبره انتشرت على مواقع تواصل اجتماعي
وانت تقبل راس والدتك في ختام منافسات
سباق الثلاثي وبعد التتويج اليوم مع عبد
الله ماذا تقول لوالدتك على الهواء مباشره
في صباح العربيه
يعني فرحه فرحه كبيره جميله يعني ان شاء
الله اللي انا عندي سنين همم اللي ينافس
فيها وشارك فيها بس همم شارك مع الوالده
هذا الشيء يمكن ما تحصل بعد الالعاب هذه
فرحت يعني في في فوز الوالده قبل الفوز
يعني
[موسيقى]